cher carole delga
poser des questions la souveraineté
c'est pour en revenir au cadre national
interrogée la place effective des
collectivités territoriales dans
l'organisation décentralisée de la
république comment les régions pour
qu'elles se saisir au côté de l'état les
grands enjeux de réindustrialisation
d'indépendance alimentaire et
énergétique et permettent à notre pays
de renouer avec la souveraineté dans
chacun de ces domaines
poser cette question ouverte par la
crise sanitaire amplifiée par la crise
énergétique et les impératifs de la
transition écologique s'est aussi
interrogé notre réponse collective à la
crise démocratique face à la progression
mécanique de l'abstention est la perte
du lien citoyen
est-il possible
de réparer les multiples fractures qui
traversent la société française
sans en appeler aux forces vives des
territoires c'est déjà la réponse à mon
interrogation ça n'est pas possible je
crois en effet que nous pouvons répondre
à cette question que par une grande
décentralisation de toutes les
politiques de proximité c'est à cette
condition que nous renouerons avec la
confiance c'est le sens de la tribune
que les 22 présidents de régions et
collectivités territoriales vous avez
signé dimanche
vous inviter une nouvelle fois à une
vraie grande réforme de la
décentralisation fait et vous plaidez
pour 1 et à renforcer recentrer sur les
sujets régaliens en donnant toute
latitude d'agir aux pouvoirs locaux
j'insiste sans injonction
ni obstruction
oui le relèvement de la france ce sera
en prenant appui sur les forces vives de
nos territoires
l'organisation décentralisée de notre
république une et indivisible et sources
non de fragilité mais de richesse
dès lors que les libertés locales ont
bien pour corollaire la pleine
responsabilité des compétences exercées
c'est me semble-t-il l'esprit de votre
tibet vous l'avez d'ailleurs intitulé
ensemble
élevons la france
c'était l'esprit de la contribution
qu au nom du sénat j'avais remise au
président de la république au sortir de
la première vague du coït 19 les 50
propositions pour une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation issue
des travaux de l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du sénat
c'est aussi
l'esprit dans lequel est président
fondateur des territoires j'ai dit à
l'automne 2010 8 et je me souviens bien
de hervé morin françois bonneau nous
accueillons dans ce rendez vous qui a
marqué un véritable tournant
oui les présidents fondateurs de thé riz
noir vu ni quand il décidé à me s'unir
pour proposer un vrai pacte de confiance
entre l'état et des collectivités
territoriales
pleinement responsable de leur politique
l'exécutif n'a pas su s'emparer
complètement de ses propositions après
l'échec de la conférence des territoires
la grande loi de proximité de
décentralisation annoncé par le
président de la république et nous
l'avons vu tout à l'heure à l'issue du
grand débat s'est traduite par des
textes qui n'ont pas répondu à toutes
les attentes même si la loi 3ds a permis
quelques avancées et je veux saluer ici
les coudes dont avait fait preuve le
premier ministre jean castex c'est le
pays tout entier
qui demandait demande plus de proximité
plus de liberté à l'échelle des
territoires
avec virulence
violence les gilets jaunes emporté en
quelque sorte ce message des élus locaux
ont su canaliser la violence et se faire
porter de propositions ils ont aussi
démontré leur agilité leur capacité à
innover au plus fort de la crise
sanitaire mais c'est une
recentralisation à bas bruit qui s'est
poursuivi la mise sous tutelle des plus
grandes collectivités par le pack de
cahors et les récents disques à qui on
remplaçait l'impôt local par des
dotations et rompu le lien entre le
contribuable de citoyens au détriment de
la responsabilité
l'abstention électorale mes chers
collègues scrutin après scrutin ça doit
nous interroger mais malheureusement
sorti renforcé
j'ai le sentiment que nos concitoyens se
reconnaissent plus dans cette
distribution des pouvoirs et ils ont le
sentiment de ne plus être entendu pour
réconcilier les français avec l'action
publique nous devons donc tout revoir en
termes de méthode et sur le fond ce
n'est pas de plus de débat dont nous
avons besoin mais d'actions il faut agir
rapidement et concrètement en revoyant
profondeur les équilibres entre le
pouvoir central et les territoires
méthode tout d'abord je salue madame la
première ministre nos premiers échanges
et ceux intervenus avec les associations
d'élus sur la base d'un dialogue que
nous souhaitons tous
sincère et ouvert ces conditions sont
d'autant plus nécessaires al'approche de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
que les élus locaux attendent oui ils
attendent d'être précisément informés
sur les modalités de leur participation
à l'effort de redressement des comptes
publics mais j'y reviendrai j'ai entendu
que le président de la république
voulait un vrai chantier je cite de
décentralisation le sénat lui
engage le travail sur la
décentralisation
sa mission constitutionnelle de
représentants des territoires et de
législateur nous y oblige la réflexion
initiée il y a plus de deux ans pour le
renforcement des libertés locales invite
tout naturellement
approfondir ses propositions
j'installerai donc le 5 octobre prochain
au sénat j'en fais l'annoncent au
congrès des régions de france le groupe
de travail pluraliste sur la
décentralisation jeu le président ray le
rapporteur général sera françois noël
buffet président de la commission des
lois et il aura à ses côtés en tant que
co rapporteurs françoise gatel
présidente de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et mathieu
darnaud président de la délégation
sénatoriale à la prospective
dans le prolongement des 50 propositions
pour le plein exercice des libertés
locales dont certaines ont déjà trouvé
une traduction législative
nous y traiteront d'abord de deux
questions qui nous paraissent
essentielles
celle des relations financières entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales est celle d'un
approfondissement de la différenciation
territoriales un nouveau texte de loi
qui ne prendraient pas en compte et en
considération d'urgence de ces deux
questions me semble vouée à l'échec
ce sont les composantes essentielles de
toute nouvelle réforme territoriale et
le socle en est l'autonomie financière
des collectivités
territoriales nous devons renouveler
profondément ici il faut pas que ce soit
simplement une forme des chevaux tôt
ou d'attention de prière le pacte
financier qui lie les collectivités à
l'état autour de trois engagements des
ressources stables
sécurisé et planifier la réévaluation
régulière des compensations versées au
titre des transferts de compétences une
contractualisation partagé et non subie
la stabilité des ressources des
collectivités territoriales doit être
restaurée les réformes successives de
leur fiscalité ont mis à mal un système
rendu complexe par les péréquations et
des transferts de charges parfois
injuste entre collectivités je veux
rappeler que les dotations globales dont
bénéficient les collectivités constitue
la contrepartie effective des transferts
de compétences successifs et les
différentes réformes qui les ont privés
de leurs ressources propres or sans
maîtrise dans le temps et joe style dans
le temps du niveau de ses ressources il
n'est plus de libre administration
la tenue d'un débat annuel sur les
finances locales qui permet de fixer un
cap pour les dotations et qui permet
d'actualiser les compensations des
transferts de compétences peut-être
madame la présidente houle aviez évoqué
dans le livre blanc des régions une des
solutions la dynamique
des ressources transférées doit prendre
en compte le dynamisme des charges
transférées
le sénat a considéré que ce principe
devait être garantie
constitutionnellement
après nous avoir entendus je veux dire
un mot des interrogations qui demeurent
quant à la contribution
des collectivités au redressement des
comptes publics autour déjà que les
collectivités ont su assumer
les baisses drastiques
engagées en 2015 et la stabilité de
leurs dotations ensuite quand
l'inflation même contenu était déjà bien
réelle
je crois madame la première ministre que
le gouvernement devra préciser ses
intentions d'ici à la publication du
projet de loi de finances 2010 23 quant
à la modération des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités jeu
reprend les mots du ministre la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires je ne doute pas que vous
aurez à coeur de promouvoir un dialogue
sincère avec des associations d'élus
locaux en amont de cette publication et
lors de son examen par le parlement les
collectivités locales sont aujourd'hui
en première ligne temps pour maintenir
des services publics locaux essentiels
face à l'inflation des coûts tant pour
cela que pour réaliser les
investissements structurants de la
transition écologique la transformation
des mobilités nous l'évoquions ce matin
celle de l'habitat ou de la gestion de
l'eau je salue à ce titre la mise en
place du fonds vert pour les
collectivités
après la méthode sur le fond de la
réforme territoriale nous aurons à coeur
d'approfondir les conditions d'exercice
du droit à la différenciation donner
plus de marges d'action collectivités
c'est leur permettent de répondre plus
efficacement à nos concitoyens sans
remettre en cause le caractère unitaire
de la république le principe de
différenciation s'applique d'ailleurs
déjà aujourd'hui dans les outre-mer et
aussi en corse et en alsace nous pouvons
aller plus loin le sénat a proposé la
possibilité d'un véritable pouvoir
réglementaire aux collectivités
territoriales pour l'exercice de leurs
compétences locales
s'agissant des outre-mer salue les
collègues j'ai vu dans un jeu de données
ou territoires ultramarins la
possibilité d'une organisation et de
normes qui répondent à leurs réalités
dans le cadre de la république le grand
texte de décentralisation que nous
appelons de nos voeux est un nouvel état
d'esprit en fait la répartition actuelle
des compétences entre collectivités
n'appelle pas de modifications profondes
pas puisqu'une grande vague de
transferts sans doute gagner et on a
confié le pilotage des politiques de
l'emploi en région j'y reviens déjà
compétente pour la formation sans doute
faut-il compléter la loi d'orientation
sur les probabilités en permettant
région d'organiser avec les
intercommunalités les métropoles et
l'ensemble des acteurs de terrain le
financement et la programmation des
transports du quotidien le sujet des
transports ferrés notamment en région
est aujourd'hui un sujet posé et qui
sera posée par le sénat je crois à
cheikh carole delga que cet objectif
pourrait s'incarner dans les agences de
mobilité que vous souhaitez mettre en
place et dans de nombreux domaines
désormais les collectivités doivent
surtout mettre en place des stratégies
globales et coordonnées à l'échelle de
leur territoire pour des enjeux aussi
fort que la transition écologique ou la
santé je sais cher laurent wauquiez vous
avez fait de la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux une de vos priorités dans votre
région en lien avec les départements en
lien avec les communes et les
intercommunalités
parce que
tout à l'heure françois sauvadet l'adil
échelons haddock de la proximité c'est
bien sûr le couple département commune
mais david lisnard quelques mots nous a
dit la nécessité
l'exigence de la simplification alors je
dois le dire
cela suffit pas pour moi que l'état
doivent s'effacer bien au contraire il
doit repenser toute son organisation
territoriale en se recentrant à
l'échelon du département en cette
rentrée
les collectivités territoriales sont
confrontés à une hausse inédite des prix
de l'énergie et des matières premières
les verts
notamment et pas que parce qu'ils gèrent
des services population proximité
s'interroge sur leur capacité à garantir
le fonctionnement
des équipements sportifs des équipements
culturels ou tout simplement leur
capacité à gérer des tarifs pour la
restauration scolaire
face à ces difficultés
au delà des réponses des réponses votée
cet été nous devons collectivement
se le dit dans le cadre du débat que
nous aurons au parlement avec le
gouvernement réfléchir à un dispositif
qui garantissent leurs ressources en
intégrant les conséquences de
l'inflation
aujourd'hui plus que jamais les
relations des collectivités avec l'état
central dwc avait abordé sur le mode de
la coopération d'un retour à une
relation de confiance j'ai entendu
parler de co construction mais ça
suppose de changer de logiciel
d'avoir un logiciel moins verticale
moins directif plus ouvert aux
initiatives locales je le dis notre pays
a besoin de ces régions pour réussir sa
ré industrialisation faire émerger les
compétences nécessaires à chacune des
filières la france a besoin de ces
départements chef de file des politiques
de cohésion sociale pour recoudre les
fractures de notre pays la france a
besoin de ces communes et ces
intercommunalités garante des services
publics locaux essentiels à la vie du
quotidien
alors la france a besoin de l'énergie de
ces territoires je le redis vous êtes
vous la première ligne mais comme au
rugby la première ligne c'est important
il faut aussi des piliers en tous les
cas le sénat entend soutenir la première
ligne en étant un pilier pour la
décentralisation merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]